- Hello, I am Pratheek
Karnati, Security Architect
for IBM Cloud.
Today we are going to look
at IBM Cloud Data Shield
and how it enables you to protect
your containerized applications
data in use or in memory.
We are going to see this
in action with the help
of a demo application we
built called Cloud Fund.
But first, let's talk
about data protection.
We believe it requires protection of data
throughout its life cycle.
In transit, at rest, and also in use.
And we have been on a
mission to address that
with confidential computing
which protects data
in use by performing computation
in hardware-based trusted
execution environment.
And Data Shield, is a deployment time tool
that helps you adopt
confidential computing
on x86 platforms.
Specifically, Intel
Software Guard Extensions
with no code changes.
Let's see how this works.
Cloud Fund is a Python app
we built for this demo.
And yes, we Data Shield power
by Fortanix Runtime Encryption
in addition to C/C++.
We also support Java, Python
and RUST runtimes on SGX.
Cloud Fund is a containerized application
running on Kubernetes,
Cloud Fund is a typical
three-tier application with a UI,
backend API and a database.
For the database, we are using
confidential database service
from a portfolio called
Hyper Protect MongoDB.
So it is very secure.
For this demo, let's focus
on the threat vectors
that come at the backend API layer
and how it privileged
user infrastructure admin,
for example, with no access
to database can steal
sensitive data from the
backend API's memory.
As a narrative element for this demo,
we are using Cloud Fund to
donate money to a charity.
Let's see how it works.
So I open the Cloud Fund
application in the browser.
I click donate now.
Here I'm giving the
details and importantly,
I'm giving the personal information
and also the credit card number.
And the expiration date and
the CVV and click submit.
Now the data goes through the backend API.
Now let's see how it privileges
that attack and play out.
Here I'm logged into the
server as privileged user.
So how my terminal open.
I'm trying to log into
the workload in question,
once I'm in there, let's
find the processing question.
The Python app I was talking about.
Once I have that, let's find a PID.
Once I have that let's memory dump it.
Now let's look for strings
in the memory dump.
That's a lot of data
let's ask for my name.
As you can see, this is a problem.
This application is vulnerable
to privileges that attacks
targeting its memory contents.
Now let's see how you can
protect your applications data
and use the Data Shield.
Let's take a look at Data
Shield documentation.
You start your journey in
the getting started page.
One of the first things you
do is you have the right
cluster.
The right worker node.
And you run a couple of
commands for prerequisites
and you install Data Shield
through this helm shot.
The places value for the
chart name, your email ID,
account ID on English subdomain.
And you get your dedicated
singleton instance
of Data Shield running
natively on your cluster.
Now let's look at the UI.
You log into the UI using IBM token.
Once your in there,
you can manage your worker nodes
and look at the attestation reports.
You can create apps and
bills for your pipelines.
You can create tasks so it
can approved or denied build.
On the user section, you
can add your teammates
or you can manage them.
Now let's go back to the
application and see how easy it is
to convert your application
from its current state
to runtime memory encrypted counterpart.
Since Data Shield is a
deployment time tool,
you don't have to make
any changes to your code.
You make this API code from
your CICD pipeline prior
to deployment of your application.
Replaces values here with your
application container name
and the new name for the new
SGX capable image we create
for you.
When you call this API
since it gives Data Shield,
read-write privileges to
your container registry
at installation.
Data Shield pulls the
current image converts
and packages to SGX capable counterpart
and pushes the new image
back to your registry.
Now you continue with your CD process
and deploy your new runtime
memory encrypted backend API.
Let's look at the changes you
make to the YAML real quick.
As you can see, all we need
is a couple of volume mounts
for SGX drivers.
You can find an example of
a YAML in our documentation.
Let's go ahead and deploy
this new backend API
and perform the same steps as earlier.
I'm on the terminal, I'm
deploying the new API.
Once it's up, let's go to the
browser under the same steps
as before.
I'm in the Cloud Fund,
I'm donating to Cloud Fund,
I gave my name, my address,
my telephone number, my credit card number
and my expiration date and
the CVV and click submit.
Now let's go back to the terminal again
and try to scrape for
text in the memory dump
of this process.
Here I am in the worker node.
I'm trying to search for
the process here on the PID.
Once I have the PID lets
memory dump the process.
Once we memory dump it,
let's scan for plain
text in this memory dump
and to make it easier,
let's give him a name.
But you see nothing because
the memory is encrypted.
There you have it.
In about five minutes,
you go from an application
that is vulnerable to a
runtime memory encrypted
counterpart.
Data Shield helps you and
your team do what you do best
developing stellar apps.
Data should takes the burden
off from the development
to the deployment time on how
to protect your sensitive data
in memory without any code changes.
Please give IBM Cloud Data Shield a try
and reach out if you have any questions.
Thank you.